ganz Europa schüttelt den Kopf über die
deutsche Energiepolitik sogar die
schwedische klimaaktivistin Greta
Thunberg und jetzt kommt Thunberg also
die Fridays for future Ikone findet das
unsere Atomkraftwerke weiterlaufen
sollten wenn sie schon laufen glaube ich
dass es ein Fehler wäre sie abzuschalten
und sich der Kohle zuzuwenden sagte
Thunberg bei Maischberger eine Ohrfeige
für Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
der druckst und trickst sich um die
ackerwände obwohl wir diesen Winter jede
Megawattstunde Strom brauchen werden ja
auch sie kämpfen fürs Klima aber
deutlich radikaler Gruppen wie letzte
Generation Ende Gelände oder extinction
Rebellion bei ihrer jüngsten
Protestaktion geht es um ein Gemälde im
Millionenwert
sie kleben sich vor Autobahnauffahrten
blockieren Baustellen und kleben sich an
antike Gemälde mit Millionen werten sie
stören sie empören sie machen wütend
die klimakaoten schrecken vor kaum einem
Protest mehr zurück
vergangenes Wochenende zwei Mitglieder
von extinction Rebellion kleben sich in
der National Gallery of Victoria in
Melbourne an ein Picasso Gemälde fest
während des antikriegsbildes Massaker in
Korea rund 280 Millionen Euro
das Werk bleibt unversehrt ist aber
nicht das erste Ziel
im August klebten sich zwei Mitglieder
der letzten Generation am goldenen
Rahmen der Sixtinischen Madonna in der
staatlichen Kunstsammlung Dresden mit
Sekundenkleber fest es ist eins der
berühmtesten Gemälde der Welt und Ziel
der klimaaktivisten sie wollen zeigen
dass die Klimakrise nicht mehr zu
ignorieren sei auf Kosten des Gemäldes
der Rahmen wird beschädigt
während die einen ein Gemälde
beschädigen kleben sich ihre mit
Anhänger auf den Straßen in ganz
Deutschland fest
sie wollen irritieren und erschüttern
die Nerven der Betroffenen sie liegen
blank
bescheuert warum Lavelle springbar zu
machen ja zu Bevölkerung verärgern sie
ja nur wir hängen die Zeiten hinten ran
es nervt einfach nur noch ja die wollen
arbeiten gehen das bringt doch alles
einfach nicht ja was sollen wir bitte
daran erinnern wie sind das ganz normale
Volk wenn ihr was ändern wollen dann
sollen wir zum Scholz gehen zu der
Werbung gehen oder zum habe gehen aber
wir haben nichts zu tun Rückblick vor
zwei Monaten Kapern klimaaktivisten die
lng-baustelle in Wilhelmshaven
protestieren gegen das geplante
importterminal für Flüssiggas die
Aktivisten der Gruppe Ende Gelände
setzen sich auf Baufahrzeuge um
Baumaterial besetzen einen Kran legen
das Gelände still doch ihr Gesicht
zeigen wollen sie nicht
es sind Gruppen die auf Erpressung
setzen um ihre Ziele zu erreichen das
Leben der Anderen so dermaßen zu stören
dass die Bundesregierung zum Einlenken
gezwungen wird so zumindest das Kalkül
ein Protest der momentan wenig Aussicht
auf Erfolg hat weil er wütend macht und
am Ende die falschen nervt
[Musik]